[موسيقى]
قبل 37 ربيعا ولد باحد احياء جزيره مادرا
البرتغالي وبها انطلقت مسيرته الكرويه جعل
الجد والمثابره وسيله لتحقيق احلامه فكان
لهما اراد
كريستيانو رونالدو بدا من فريق ناسيونال
قبل ان ينضم لسبورتينغ لشبونه عام 2002
وفي سن الثامنه عشر حازم حقائبه نحو
انجلترا السعر
مانشستر
النجم الاول في الفريق بل في العالم حينما
نال جائزه الكره الذهبيه سنه 2018
في عام 2009 البرتغالي اصبح اغلى لاعب في
تاريخ المستديره بصفقه انتقال بلغت قيمتها
80 مليون جنيه
في ريال مدريد تعلق رونالدو فاز بكل
الالقاب الممكنه اضاف الى خزينته الشخصيه
اربع كرات ذهبيه لتصبح خمسا في المجموعه
رونالدو عرج على فريقه يوفنتوس الايطالي
سنه 2018 ثم عاد الى مانشستر يونايتد من
جديد سنه 2021 على مستوى المنتخب ايضا نجح
في كسب رهان وتوج بلقب كاس الامم
الاوروبيه سنه 2016
ودوريه الامم الاوروبيه سنه 2019 رونالدو
انتقل الى فريق النصر السعودي في صفقه قوه
الدوري السعودي في انتظار تالق على
الملاعب السعوديه مثل ما فعل على الصعيد
اوروبا
[موسيقى]
بلال الوجداني العربيه